yes
okay so um I'm going to start the public
hearing um I'm passing out an
bill a couple of those
okay
John good morning commer
committee uh for the record my name is
representative John pusk Rockingham
13 I'm here to introduce uh House Bill
1257 relative to contracts between
Public Adjusters and the
insured uh the prime sponsor is
representative hunt and the bill
provides that a property insurance
policy shall not prohibit the insured
from hiring a public adjuster the bill
is at the request of the insurance
Department any questions can be directed
to the folks following
me thank you very much okay great thank
much
yeah yeah so the amendment I just passes
for the next bill so so people aren't
confused
yes good morning yes good morning
chairman members of the committee uh my
name is Joshua Hillyard I'm the
compliance and enforcement council at
the New Hampshire insurance department
and I want to thank you for your time
particularly the chairman who I know was
instrumental in getting this bill
forward as well as the committee to
consider it today um just brief
background uh the insurance department
initially brought this forward um really
is a prophylactic measure it's not a
concern we've seen happen in New
Hampshire but in other states uh but
we've received a number of comments and
the department would really like
additional time to considerate so what
I'd request today is that uh this bill
be marked in expedient to legislate or
whatever procedural process is best to
allow the department and other
interested parties additional time to to
consider
this good
idea happy to take any questions if
there's any
questions any questions from the
committee I guess when you say kill it
so they're not going to ask anything
more all right great thank you very much
is there anybody else would like to
speak on 125
guess
uh 25 minutes minutes yeah so yeah so
yeah okay we'll we'll we will have a
subcommittee on this bill and discuss
why why the story behind it and explain
to everybody why we don't
really to because
normally that we we would do a
subcommittee so So when you say let's
you know explore it but the department
really has no great Mo motivation to
want to pass this legislation because it
affects secondary market and you don't
really regulate that anyways right and
at this point there's no real drive to
uh there was some some insightful
comments that suggested that the the ill
this bill was uh trying to combat which
again is prophylactic in nature we
haven't seen this in the state is
already um adequately covered with the
laws that are in place um so given that
there there didn't seem to be a great
need to to pass this great perfect okay
thank
you okay I have no other cards or
one okay see I was not expecting
than
okay we'll open up the public hearing on
House Bill 1259 and here from
representative pusc good morning
representative good morning chairman
Committee uh House Bill
1259 yes an act relative to Property and
Casualty Insurance laws administered by
the insurance
department the analysis this bill
clarifies the distinction between
personal and Commercial lines in
use of electronic commun communication
for auditable basis policies and
requires the insurer to State the
specific reason for cancellation or
refusal to renew a pro policy this bill
is also a request of the insurance
department if there's any questions I'm
sure the folks following me will be
them thank you okay thank you very much
and we'll call on our property casual
Fox good
morning morning thank you very much for
having us here today yeah you have to
push the button thank
you you got to have make the red light
on there Property and Casualty Insurance
uh James Fox and he will speak to the
specific details but um thank you again
for letting us speak today okay and and
now you've introduced yourself so I'm
going to make you afterwards fill out a
pink card so so we know yes sir thank
you and welcome aboard good morning my
name is James Fox I am the PNC director
this is um what we usually like to call
our our a bit of a cleanup bill or a
modernization bill uh and it has BAS
basically if you boil it down it's got
three parts um the first part is there
is uh in Insurance Land a distinction
between commercial insurance and
personal lines insurance so if you're a
homeowner you have a personal Lin
insurance and if you're a business you
have a commercial lines and where
exactly that line is drawn uh is always
a
question um the current standard uh we
have is in the Department's opinion more
detailed than it needs to be uh we've
had uh a couple of insurance companies
come in and say they think they should
be able to write a particular product on
a a personalized basis and not have to
do a commercial lines and it was uh we
had detailed the law so much that uh I
told them that they're not allowed to
they weren't going to be allowed to do
that um after uh internal discussion we
decided that the best thing to do was to
um dial back that a little bit and just
make it that it's personal lines uh if
it's for um personal use uh is for
personal family or household needs so if
a policy is being issued by the
insurance company now for personal
family or household needs then it needs
to be on a personal line basis uh and
then usually how it works is other than
that it would be on a commercialized
basis so that's how we'll draw the line
um the department has historically not
wanted to get too into um the company's
uh business on exactly on what they're
going to um write on a personal lines
basis versus a commercial lines basis
there certain things that are clearly
must be commercial certain things
clearly need to be personal but there's
also a gray area and we think it's best
for the market to let the companies
control that uh so that was the basis
for um that change um the next change uh
is on auditable policies so if you don't
know what an audible policy is that's um
workers compensation is a classic
example that's a situation where the
company's basically estimating um the
risk UPF front and uh then estimating
your premium and then at the end of the
policy uh period they commit and they do
an audit and they determine then exactly
what you um what you should pay for that
period um the only change in that is
that it used to just say you the um
insurance company could do it by
telephone or mail um that's a bit
outdated uh Cons considering virtual
means now such as teams and zoom so now
we just want to change that to allow um
the companies to be able to interact
with their uh Insurance uh businesses uh
via uh electronic communication like
teams and zoom uh and then the last
change before the requested Amendment um
we made was that we wanted the uh
insurance companies in uh person Lin's
property to State the specific reason uh
for cancellation um which is pretty
consistent with our rules in most
instances uh but in the old version it
said um there was a more complicated uh
process for the insured to be able to
get the reason why um the cancellation
was being issued um cancellations are
pretty Limited in the state of New
Hampshire uh so we thought it would be
um better and more consumer friendly if
we just state that the insurance company
must State the basis for the
cancellation they do it in commercial
lines now this is in personal lines uh
so that we don't think that should be a
problem uh the last the last change
we're requesting is that in our adjuster
law we have this is a requested
amendment of our um uh in our commercial
in our adjusters law so we we license
adjusters so we have a claim um the
person who comes out and investigates
the claim that's the adjuster uh in uh
we have noticed that for solely glass
claims and that means your automobile
claim um that is a very uh simple
process that's generally been automated
now uh doesn't really require a human uh
at all and not a licensed human if you
if your windshield is cracked you you
are entitled to either a fix or a new
one if you have auto autog glass
coverage uh and if there's any problem
with that uh they'll the they will know
to contact the department because then
that would be a statement by the
insurance company uh that like the claim
is being denied so we don't feel that
that um almost ministerial task uh to
just swap out a piece of glass as
opposed to say there's a damage to the
car and the Damage actually to the
vehicle needs to be invest you know
investigated like well there's frame
damage there's all different kinds of
damage that are possible so it's such a
simp Le uh damage if it's solely a class
claim we'd like it to be that they don't
need to have an adjuster and um we have
noticed that the companies most of them
are wanting that change and we don't
think it in any way uh compromises the
consumer's uh protection so those are
are the kind of uh I'd call them mostly
modernization and cleanup and a little
bit of further commun uh consumer
protection in the context of a
cancellation that the uh Department uh
requests and I'm happy to take any
question
questions okay representative Gibbs has
a question thank you uh and thank you
for coming today uh can you tell us the
reason that um uh a couple of things
were deleted from the definition of
personal risk um specifically owner
occupied one to four family buildings
and mobile homes uh were deleted um sure
I can I can tell you that the the owner
occupied was actually the the driver
driving force uh for the change that we
had we had a so the over had to be
unoccupied in less than four units I
believe the old the we had a situation
where someone uh was just running out
their condo they owned a condo they were
just running out the condo and the
insurance company and that is actually
how it generally does work um wanted to
write that on a personal lined basis and
we said well it's not owner occupied so
you can't and that seemed uh internally
at the insurance department to be
inconsistent with how we thought it
should operate so that's why we wanted
to uh change to be uh not be owner
occupied and just be a decision based
upon um more of a holistic view of
what's Happening um so that the owner
occupied was actually the the the
primary problem and that's why we get
rid of that um and
the uh mobile homes uh you know that um
that I think that that was an issue with
just the language and the issue of uh
like a recreational vehicle uh and um we
didn't think it was necessary to have
that in there separate that if it's so
that would be covered still but it would
be covered uh in the sense of whether
it's just for family uh personal family
or household needs that we didn't need
to single out uh mobile homes in the
list this is for all personal risks like
we can list tons of different personal
risks and we didn't think that mobile
homes needed to be in there homeowners
is the the the the main uh one version
and then the other automobile but we
didn't feel that you needed to have a
mobile home on the list it was just like
unnecessary representative
B thank you for taking my question uh
you were talking about glass claims
they're pretty simple but they really
aren't sometimes because of the
electronics that are embedded in the
glass would you need an a uh an agent to
come and look at that to assess the
damage or how are they dealing with that
now no so um so you you're
you're the the you you get your car uh
back to pre-loss condition so pre-loss
condition in that case the insurance
companies knowe would be whatever type
of uh windshield you had so if you have
uh like my car I have an old car so it's
just a regular piece of glass you throw
in uh but in that case a high-tech
window then the insurance company knows
that they need to have a high-tech
window and that um would not need
adjustment adjust adjusters are more
like to look at the exact and like write
quotes and like this but in that case
it's very clear if you have a a win
thing where where if it rains or wind
your wipers turn on or something like
that then that is that is the the type
of glass you get um the only other ISS
issue is whether it's uh original
equipment manufacturer or aftermarket
parts but that's not that doesn't that
wouldn't involve that this issue either
so you would still get that and all the
insurance companies know that that
wouldn't be a concern you don't you
wouldn't need an adjuster for that
represent of
taon just just to be clear I've had I
have an auditable po workman's comp
policy which I complete electronically
now with my carrier I've had glass
claims with a fancy electronic
windshields which are basically carried
out between the glass shop and the the
carrier again is this not permissible
under current law you you you you you
hit the nail on the head on that one
that that that that is the issue so um
how the industry is going is that the uh
uh insurance companies have U made deals
with uh glass companies and if you call
in for just a glass claim uh that shifts
you over I won't name the name of the
company but there's one particular safe
light I will name it so uh that shifts
you to Safe Light they they do the whole
process uh and that we have not uh We've
so we've done exams on this we have not
found a problem with safe light they are
seem to be a good company we have not
found uh problems with glass claims the
only problem we found is that they don't
have adjusters license bues and then we
the require the uh insurance company at
this point to to have an adjuster um
assigned to each glass claim and then
the issue then came up why are you
requiring us to do this and then the
issue well the law says we have to do
that uh but we understand that this the
Simplicity of a glass claim um wouldn't
need that change but we said we need to
go to legislature to ask you know we're
in the enforcement Branch so we need to
go to legisl to ask them um to alter the
law uh which we've done before on uh
this is not the first time we've been
here on the adjusters first notice of
loss was another issue they technically
under the law they needed to have an
adjuster's license to do a first notice
of loss when you call the insurance
company um uh and we changed that a few
years ago to say that the first notice
of loss is uh is more of a clerical act
so you don't need that so we're kind of
trying to be um balance the you know the
the needs of Industry you don't want to
uh burden them too much because then
that's when your rates go up uh so we
want to burden them when there's a
consumer protection need to do it and uh
with glass uh our position at this point
is that there isn't now obviously if it
becomes a problem later then we would sh
we'll be back here explaining that you
know I I I will say which I've done
before I've made a mistake uh but I
think I think we're right on this we've
looked at it pretty extensively further
question me inquire so and essentially
it's the same thing with the workers
comp I mean my workers I just send them
I email them the 941s and that's
basically the end of the conversation
yeah usually it's pretty simple but you
know this was just our actuary um
thought that we should change the
language of the law because it just says
phone and mail to make it phone mail and
on like you know um a
virtual yeah uh that you could already
do but this is more for the audit in
terms of uh in terms of interacting like
the the so you could have in person so
that would be one version then um and
then you'd have uh you know the um
electronic version which would already
be uh maybe you could arue arue mail is
email but this would basically make it
clear that the insurance company and the
insured can do it all electronically
everything that needs to be
done representative
Ammon thank you Mr chair uh thank you
for bringing this legislation um in a
previous life I used to repair
windshields a long time ago um and the
way it worked in a this was a different
state um the if if a consumer got a chip
that the insurance company would just
send us out to repair the ship they
would wave the deductible uh because it
saved them from replacing the entire
windshield um and it seemed to work uh
just fine so this amendment would cover
that scenario correct yeah that would
that would be a Pure Glass claim it
it representative pelli on the
cancellation can you thank you for
taking my question on the cancellation I
was hoping that maybe you could repeat
why the language in the bill was struck
uh because uh so we have um Auto and we
have uh commercial and we have personal
lines three cancellation statutes and uh
in uh the only one that doesn't have the
states of specific reason which is what
we usually do uh in a lot of context
like if there's going to be a denial uh
is the personalized one so that's like
the the homeowner uh it didn't have it
didn't just straight say to tell them
the reason why um you're canceling them
and the insurance company will know the
reason because there only there are very
few reasons you can cancel so the the
what we used to be in there is that
you'd have to go through this process
the the consumer would need to go
through this process to get the answer
so we we didn't think it was um uh a
significant burden on the insurance
company just in the first instance to
tell in the cancellation notice why it
was being cancelled as opposed to a
process like if you contact us in
writing request U that so it's just uh
it's just a pro consumer change great
thank you thank
you um so actually
um a couple of these are actually are
strike home the home for me uh today or
this week um and it would be a employers
uh commercial but I had uh a deer attack
the side of a one of my employees trucks
and uh and of course the the insurance
company think it was only Liberty
mutuals only thought it was going to be
$2,600 and and we haven't got any quotes
less than 6,000 for it but uh that's a
commercial but everything is done online
now I mean none of these are these
agents or adjusters are not New
Hampshire based they're even though
Liberty Mutual does have business here
but I I don't know if they the only
requirement they have to be uh licensed
in New Hampshire but we they can be
based a lot of different places but they
need to be licensed here so that license
must be fairly inexpensive right they
are uh I don't know exact number but
they are that is one of when uh so when
when companies so no matter where the
company is if the ACT if if the accident
involves a New Hampshire insured we say
that they have to have a a New Hampshire
license uh because they're adjusting
with all of our rules and then they say
Well we'd have to pay for that and then
I know uh um the answer usually is it's
very inexpensive to do that so and if
you have an adjustor who's already
licensed in another state it's very easy
to get a New Hampshire license but it's
for the fundamental purpose that if
there was a Consumer complaint that you
have uh reason to uh talk to the company
and this adjuster and say you sure you
want to take that stance otherwise we
might pull your license correct yeah
John hun another lever on the yeah
adjusters like to protect their licenses
okay uh section one um ironically where
this strikes to home for me a little bit
is that my home is a vacation
rental and some people think that's a
commercial application now so far the
courts have pretty much held up that is
a residential and I guess I would guess
have you had any problems with vacation
rentals when it comes to is the property
the properly insured and with the
insurer pay for it's insured that that
is that is everybody seems to come the
reason we're doing these things that
that is the reason the primary driver
behind this though is that some when you
said some people think this some people
think that um we didn't feel that the
insurance department should should in in
require um the insurance every insurance
company to to view
uh specific fact patterns one way
because the in very detail because uh
and that may sound nice uh in a certain
context in a vacuum but the problem is
when you um tell a company exactly you
must do it this way in very detailed and
that means every time it falls outside
that detail then they don't do it that
way even though you no I meant you I no
that one you should do that way too so
it's it the Department's experience um
and this really started in Auto uh when
we when we did the as most people
probably know we have a take all Comer
state so insurance companies you have to
sell to everybody and one of the things
we're going to put we did a bulletin
we're going to put in the bulletin we're
going to explain the the exact line
between personal lines and Commercial
lines and that became um quite a
discussion and quite a a disagreement
and then it got to the point where they
this this should not be in a bulletin
and the department should not be taking
a strong stance we should have The
Stance of the insurance companies should
operate their businesses and if it's my
the word I use if it passes a straight
face test that then it's that's fine uh
if if a a particular insured doesn't
doesn't think it should be uh um for
example if they say this a commercial
we're not going to view it as a as a a
personal in this particular fact pattern
then you know the the Department's uh
always position in a lot of areas is
then you should shop your insurance we
have competitive market we have a lot of
different insurance companies you can go
to so sh shop shop your your business as
opposed to locking the insurance
companies in and then having unattended
consequences which are significantly
worse for the consumer so uh that means
that it's really up to the insurance
company whether they want to treat it as
a personal residence or a commercial
residence as long as for for as a
straight face we could say it falls
within personal family or household
needs that is the the last sentence is
going to control everything before that
but at the end of the day it's really
their decision what they want to cover
it's going to they have it's the
obligations on them to make that
determination right and then we do
Market conduct and if we we went in on a
market conduct basis and we said this
company is not listening not following
the the the three three rules of
personal family or household needs then
we would say you got to stop that you
got to change direction so that's how we
handle that so it's a one of our units
goes into insurance companies and tests
these things perfect thank you thank you
any other questions from the committee
members uh see none we thank you very
much thank you
[Music]
and I don't think I have any other cars
right nobody else wants to speak on this
okay we
sheets
okay so we have George Rose hose is in
support and Joan Pino is also in support
and Jim hayum is in
support and we close the public
here
okay
very
testimony
welcome to Commerce thank you Mr chair
and thank you members of the committee
for the record I am representative Jose
cambrils maram County District 4
representing the towns of Canterbury and
Lowden I speak to you today on this
organ donor Rights bill as someone who
received a life saving kidney transplant
just four years ago so I am very
familiar with with all aspects of the
organ donation and Transplant
process HB 1155 the living donor
protection
act is a common sense bipartisan bill as
its name implies this law would simply
protect any living organ donor from
losing or being able to obtain life
insurance and all would also protect
them from discriminatory premium hikes
on the sole basis of their having
donated uh an organ to somebody
what I have found is that insurance
companies have a wide range of policies
both written and Unwritten when it comes
to this subject matter and those that do
not discriminate
now could do so in the future
discrimination against living organ
donors has can and could continue to
occur without this
law the reality is that organ donors
have to be in Superior Health in order
to be a donor in the first place they go
through a a very rigorous health
screening before they allow before they
are allowed to donate some insurance
companies then punish them calling their
organ donation a preexisting condition
in practice they should be giving the
organ donors discounts on their
insurance given that they have been
proven to be in excellent health and the
fact that they just saved another
person's life thus saving the company
from paying out death insurance for that
individual this law is not asking for
favorable or special treatment for
living organ
donors it is just asking for equal
treatment and protection against
penalties you can see that this bill has
been co-sponsored by leadership in both
the house and the Senate from both
Republican and Democrat parties I
respectfully request and ought to pass
recommendation from this
committee I would like to defer the rest
of my time and your questions to John
Hoffman he is here today to testify as
the senior director of State policy and
advocacy for the National Kidney fund he
is the subject matter expert on this
issue thank you Mr chair and committee
morning thank you for the opportunity to
speak before you
today there you go is it on now sorry
yeah it's always it's always a learning
experience thank you for the opportunity
to speak before you today on behalf of
the people we serve in New Hampshire
including 1,881 residents currently
living with endstage renal disease we
respectfully request that you support HB
1155 sponsored by representative camell
this important bill would prohibit life
disability and long-term care insurance
providers from discrimination solely on
the basis of the status of being a
living organ donor the American Kidney
fund is the nation's leading nonprofit
organization working on behalf of the 37
million Americans living with kidney
disease and the millions more at risk
with an unmatch scope of programs that
support people wherever they are in
their fight against kidney disease from
prevention through transplant today in
the United States there are 103,000
people on a waiting list for an organ
transplant including more than 990,000
who are waiting for a kidney the wait
for a kidney transplant from a deceased
donor can last years and 13 people die
every day waiting for a kidney this is
where living donors come in they save
lives with the selfless Act of donating
a kidney and we need to do everything we
can to protect them and make more living
donation possible when someone donates a
kidney to a relative a friend or a
stranger they shorten the transplant
waiting list for everyone else in
addition kidneys from living D living
organ donors generally last longer than
kidneys from deceased donors nearly
7,000 living donor kidney transplants
were performed last year including 14
here in New Hampshire kidneys are the
most common organ transplanted from
living donors followed by liver and Lung
in addition to transforming the lives of
kidney patients organ transplant can
have a significant economic impact if a
person of working age gets a kidney
transplant they are often able to return
to a normal life without dialysis and
resume working as most dialysis patients
are not able to work the cost of a
transplant is lower than long-term
kidney dialysis HB 1155 helps to
encourage becoming a living organ donor
in New Hampshire by removing a potential
hurdle by prohibiting that
discrimination we talked about insurance
insurers in 18 states in Washington DC
where there is no prohibition against
discrimination can deny coverage raise
existing donor premiums or resend
existing life insurance coverage after
organ donation is disclosed this problem
is widespread but underreported in 2014
the American Journal of transplantation
wrote among 186 donors who changed or
initiated life insurance after donation
46 or 25% of them reported difficulty
among those who reported difficulty 23
were denied altogether 27 were charged a
higher premium and 177 were told they
have a pre-existing condition because
they were kidney donors in this single
Center study a high proportion of kidney
donors reported difficulty changing or
initiating Insurance particularly life
insurance these practices by insurers
create unnecessary burden and stress for
those choosing to donate and could
negatively impact the likelihood of Life
kidney donation among those
considering this discrimination need not
be Universal among insurance companies
to be an active impediment to organ
donation people who are considering
becoming a donor may receive a new quote
or an impression from their existing
life insurer that rates may increase and
they will walk away or can walk away
from the process leaving that person
with organ failure to search for another
match Nicole a nurse practitioner living
here in New Hampshire who I spoke to
yesterday lost her mother last April
from anage penal disease she waited six
years for a matching organ donor while
she was on dialysis but none came this
bill has passed in 32 states is
bipartisan and noncontroversial the
National Council of insurance
legislators has authored consensus model
legislation that this bill is based on
the American Council of life insurers
has supports this particular Bill and
federal legislation that is looking to
address the same issue we believe that
removing Financial burdens for living
donors can lead to an increase in organ
donations for these reasons we're
hopeful for your support of this
legislation that can improve the lives
of those fighting organ failure thank
you again uh for your consideration of
this critical issue for all those
reasons we respectfully as ask that you
do report this bill I look forward to
answering any questions that you might
have representative Terry thank you uh
so I'm just curious as to how
nious the life insurance companies or
the companies that offer life insurance
and long-term care are with respect to
existing policy holders um are there
Provisions written into LTC policies and
life insurance policies that if you
happen to be an organ donor you can be
cancelled if you if you donate an organ
During the period of time which you are
are
covered uh so I I'm thinking personally
right now because that's where I begin
in so I have a life insurance policy I
have a long-term care policy if if I
were to donate a
kidney I'm first of all I'm wondering
how the life insurance company or the
LTC company is going to find out that I
did that but let's just say that they
did would they be able to cancel because
somewhere in my policies there's a
provision that they can do that or are
they cancelling under some broader
non-specific term thank you typically
that study that I mentioned in the in in
my testimony mentioned that it's treated
as a pre-existing condition for for new
people for new people that's your point
uh and it's only disclosed people tend
to disclose those things on an annual
basis if they're if they're considering
doing it less so after the fact to your
point uh so they are terminating
Insurance uh based I think on a there's
not there's not a specific written
component in their insurance where
they're able to do it it's your point
it's not it's not something that's
written down in policy follow up please
for the question do you do do do you
have any you cited a bunch of Statistics
do you have any uh
statistics that indicate the uh the
scope of the problem with respect to
existing policy holders being cancelled
because the company finds out that the
insured has donated in Oregon do do you
have any data on that I don't I because
you got 32 states that have done this
just wondering somebody must have asked
this question I can't imagine I'm the
first you're not the challenge is
typically with those who have yet to get
can get coverage that's why I spoke
about the ones addressed those are the
ones we are most reaching out for
because those are people that are
proactively searching or asking the
question there are some that are having
their coverage terminated but it's a
much smaller problem based on I think
what I said in the testimony was in that
study uh of the 186 the 45 the 25% that
reported difficulty uh 27 were charged a
higher premium but none none in this
particular study were terminated from
existing coverage it was just the
perspective future donors great thank
you
okay represent Mader um thank you very
much Mr chairman I I just want to
clarify this I I actually was life
insurance licensed way back when and the
only thing we had back then was like a
two-year incontestability Clause so
nothing like this would have happened
how how but you're telling me if if I
get this straight that policies that are
written now actually include this in
other words if uh if it's three years
you become a donor we can cancel you or
or or raise your premium is that correct
that's what's happening for the for this
population in this study and and how
long has that been going on these bills
new I would think these bills have been
uh in play since I think 2016 2017 when
this started to become addressed the
federal bill was introduced for the
first time three congresses ago uh this
is uh the reason why so I mentioned en
coil so the National Council of
insurance legislators took this up
because they were brought this the same
study that I'm mentioning about this 25%
this large I mean that's a large number
of potential buyers who are being
dissuaded from becoming living organ
doners that's why they supported the
bill that's why they wrote model
language because they were realizing
that this is a growing problem one
that's new because I think also uh more
attention is being paid to live organ
donation now uh than previously I think
maybe when you were covering that was
not as pervasive of a and and we like
we're we're happy about that right we're
glad that it's becoming more commonplace
but I think that's been the the increase
in number of ations is leading to the
increase in number of people who are
scrutinized
spear thank you so I know that the
prognosis for uh a person receiving a
kidney transplant is very good and they
go on to live pretty pretty good lives
like the rest of us uh how about the
donors do they have any kind of let's
you have some numbers on how well they
do sure yeah I think that's a great
question I think the reason the reason
underpinning the this entire Bill and
why discrimination is inappropriate is
that there's no additional actual oil
risk for someone who's given a kidney uh
if they if they've gone through the
process where they have been tested they
are deemed healthy they're able to give
this kidney they're going to have just
as long and positive of a life that they
would have had beforehand kidney is the
only organ that you have essentially a
spare of your numbers are the same
before and after you donate as far as
your blood work goes uh so those people
who are able to donate are already as as
mentioned previously by the bill sponsor
they're already have indicated a high
level of Health that they they are they
are super fit uh to to continue doing
this so they're able to run marathons
after the fact they're able to have the
same healthy life that they had
beforehand except for now another person
uh has had their life dramatically
extended by by that organ donation I I
got to I got to cut in here
um most of our insurance regul and I
assumed it was all but I do know life
insurance is a a whole different animal
but because you can
be be tested for pre-existing condition
I conditions in you but generally you
can't um rate someone on something that
you don't have evidence that that is is
statistically correct so does life
insurance exempt from that've requ sorry
they've been using from the from the
Judgment of from the Judgment of those
two groups those National groups they've
been using data that is not supported by
other signs so they're able because
there's no regulation on this particular
finding they're able to use either their
own proprietary information
non-medically accepted data that says
that life outcomes are different for
donors or that actual risk is higher for
for people so they found some some
something to offer it up to defend their
using this as a that's understanding as
a rating
Factor okay but enco so enco rejected
that
their that finding correct they they
they looked at the the same scientific
data they had legislators present and
they said that we you know from our
understanding and all the data we've
been presented there is no additional
actual risk so we believe that a
legislation at the federal level which
sets a floor for an understanding for
all insurance providers is necessary and
in lie of that we passed it in 32 states
try that that brings up a whole another
can of worson to think of how of what
else is going on in the ins in life
insurance Market where these actuarials
are are cooking up the numbers I can't
speak to that
[Laughter]
unfortunately okay representat Terry
again um so I can Envision how this
could happen with a situation where
somebody is applying for life insurance
or long-term care and they disclose the
person discloses I I was a an organ
donor okay um I'm I'm fully in support
of the bill but so I I can understand
how how that could happen and we want to
deal with that in this bill will you do
what I'm trying to understand a is is
that a life insurance policy a long-term
care policy is is effectively a contract
what language in these
contracts is being appealed to or
utilized I should say is being utilized
as a basis for discontinuing coverage to
a policy holder who's become an organ
donor during the time in which the
person is a policy holder sure what what
provision are they
utilizing do this i' like where what is
the language and where is it speak I'd
like to sort of consult with my with my
co-workers to try to figure what that is
I think it varies by state what
particular Clause is being either
violated or or being appealed to and so
if I'd like to provide that subsequently
to this hearing I'd like to do that
would you get that I'm really curious I
would venture to say that most people
this occurs when they renew their
driver's license representative Gibs
thank you uh there's no additional
Actuarial risk for uh living kidney
donors do you have similar information
for donors of other types of organs for
liver and for I don't I don't have it
with me as well but I I I can I can only
speak to kidneys I know that the
recovery process for liver donation is a
lot longer than that of kidney I think
it's two to three times longer but I
believe the same uh just as just as
kidneys uh donors have to go through a a
very rigorous screening and matching
process I believe that the outcomes are
similar to kidney but I can speak only
with with sever like high levels of
confidence about
grassy my question is sort of on the
line of Representative Terry's questions
is and the concern I have are you seeing
this in in mainstream insurance carriers
or is this something that's coming up
with just some of these Fly by Night
insurance they give you a really really
low rates but really really crappy
coverage I think that's a great question
I think we have seen the larger National
organizations support this legislation
likely because they are not themselves
part of this discrimination so it's a
it's really I think you know uh I know
all state is generally supportive of
legislation uh in this space there are
some other larger groups that have
indicated not being in opposition to
them so I think I think to your point I
think that there is a a likely chance
that there are some of the minor players
who are operating in in a this is this
is a non-regulated not life insurance is
not a non-regulated space but this
particular element of of risk assessment
and and and actual roal risk assessment
is is Curr further question so what
you're saying is that most of the
mainstream uh insurance carriers support
this legislation right and then and then
the council the organization that that
they are part
of Representative piselli oh thank you
for taking my question this is an issue
I'm sure we were not aware of However
unfortunately I have family experience
with bone marrow transplant which is not
technically an organ I guess so would
that type of um issue be covered under
this bill we have not heard of a lot of
discrimination for bone marrow uh donors
in this in this in this way we we tend
to work uh when we do other legislation
that addresses uh unpaid and paid leave
we do a lot more with that particular
Community um but as far as we have not
heard about them being subject to the
same levels of discrimination from uh
it would be it would be we just we just
they're not thank
you represent believe thank you for
taking my question it's not about
insurance but it's about uh donors um if
a young person um dies in a car accident
and he doesn't have it listed on his
card that he would be a donor could the
parents decide that um he was going to
be a donor do you know that I don't for
New Hampshire I'm not sure if there's
this particular regul about that in the
state but I can't speak to that thanks
okay thank you very much I have one more
card left I represent muns
who promises a
two-minute oh statement of support did
he did you get a card can you thank you
Mr chairman um it's good to be back at
the in front of the committee twice in
one week real treat for me so thank you
um
for the record uh my name is Chris muns
I represent uh Hampton in rockium County
District 29 and also for the record um
my daughter is the assistant
communication director for the American
Kidney fund uh she works with um with
John in their office in Washington and
um her grandmother my mother passed away
from kidney failure and she brought this
bill to my attention
and I wanted to just share with you our
family's experience um following heart
surgery my mother had complications
resulting in the failure of both of her
kidneys uh putting her on twice a week
dialysis she was too old for a
transplant but she had but had she been
eligible she would have jumped at the
chance she was always an active
person uh and being tied to a dialysis
machine uh just wasn't her thing so she
made the courageous decision to end
those treatments and that is what uh
eventually killed
her I saw what kidney damage can do to a
loved one and as legislators we should
do whatever we can to ensure that anyone
any that any that as many people as
possible who wish to be potential donors
have the opportunity to do so so that
those people in need of an organ can
benefit from it if this bill um if this
bill ensures that one living donor is
able to help one person like my mother
continue to live a long and fruitful
life then it is worth it and with that I
hope that you will recommend this as
ought to pass I'm happy to take any
questions but I know that chairman hunt
wants me to move on
so
okay we do have a question
representative
M uh thank you actually this is not a
question but I think um it would be
helpful not actually this I'm all for
this bill but I'm very curious as to
what uh language that an insurance
company might put in a policy that says
this and perhaps you could get that to
us thank
you thank you because I couldn't have
okay great thank you yeah so she just
wants your
testimony make yeah it makes her life
easier okay uh have no more
cards and let's see uh Peter Lehman is
in support of the bill and and Ben
Bradley who was here is also from the
hospital Association is in support of
the bill and with that we will close the
minutes
[Laughter]
bye
so I can say I was looking at the
CL we have both of them both have
different times but neither neither one
is right I'm
told
so good morning good morning thank you
Mr chair you want me to Y thank you're
on thank you Mr chairman the members of
the House Commerce Committee
representative Joe Sweeney uh
representing the town of Salem
Rockingham 25 here to introduce my bill
House Bill 1507 and act relative to
Innovative Financial Services I have
given you all a copy of my testimony so
I'm not just going to do the classic
read off of the letter um as I'm aware
you all can can read it for yourself but
this bill is proposing a Sandbox for
financial tech services within the state
of New Hampshire what that what that
means is when it comes to regulatory
sandboxes it will allow Uh current
players in the financial services
industry as well as outside uh groups
that are looking to come into New
Hampshire to offer Financial Services uh
to be set up in a regulatory sandbox
that can examine some of the regulations
that we place on Financial Services uh
and and relax those regulations within
the sandbox while still making making
sure that consumers are protected and
that the state's interests are protected
uh just to see kind of as a a a real
world example of some regulations that
we've had on the books for years that
might not still be serving uh the same
way that they were intended to be
serving the state when they were put in
place uh in regard just to financial
services um I think we're seeing a lot
and I'm sure your committee has dealt a
lot uh with blockchain technology and
new emerging Technologies when it comes
to financial services and this will just
kind of provide a vehicle
uh for a regulatory sandbox to exist
within New Hampshire for financial Tech
um some other states have gone forward
with such sandboxes that they've
implemented um in the financial Tech
sector and other sectors as well um and
I think it's just a it's an opportunity
for us to allow for the market and for
the for financial services to uh create
some new products and bring some new
products to Consumers here in New
Hampshire I'm happy to take any
questions I know I have some others in
support here as well and all the hands
all the hands let's go so we start in
one and representative San thank you uh
can you just kind of give you said
there's other states that have this can
you give me some examples like
illustrate so I can like really sure
it's been recent but I believe Arizona
went through with a a financial regul uh
sandbox um in recent years so there
hasn't been but what does it look like
in practice is what I'm asking so it's
it's essentially a relaxed regulatory
framework work for the industry in
question so it's not it's it's not
always Financial Tech when when states
are looking at sandboxes it's just an
ability for um for for Industries to
play in the sandbox s to speak and relax
regulatory uh but all all has to be
approved under this bill all Provisions
all all products still have to be
approved by the banking Department um so
it's not like they get it's not wild
wild west free reain there's still still
guidance there and followup for the
question may inquire so
I'm I'm struggling to understand the the
point I mean listen I like the idea of
reduced regulations if you if you think
there's a regul regulatory problem um it
sounds like this is sort of like we're
creating maybe a loophole versus just
fixing a current regulatory problem or
like what what is the problem you're
trying to solve so I wouldn't call it
creating I I wouldn't consider it
creating a loophole I think it's just
giving an opportunity to test some new
products out in New Hampshire that
otherwise under current regulations
wouldn't be allowed and I will say there
there are others here to speak on this
bill that are a little more
knowledgeable than I am exactly on it
all right okay represent
spear thank you
uh I we've seen a lot of products uh
banking type products or monetary
products come through this
committee based on what I'm reading here
and I'm not an expert on exactly what
this says but I could see a bank setting
up a
cryptocurrency and I can see that if
they don't have to F we don't have any
structure for that we have no legal
structure for such a thing as that uh so
that would be like a freewheeling thing
that would absolutely I don't see where
there's any protection for the consumer
or for the state for that matter so they
still have to follow all laws on the
books and they have to be permitted by
the banking Department to operate in
this sandbox it just allows the the
Pro product producer the financial
institution that's producing the product
and the banking Department to work out
the
details themselves without having to to
rewrite statute follow follow question
forther question me inquire give me an
example of such a
product the the the purpose of a Sandbox
isn't to have a product in mind for I
don't I don't have an example for you
it's to allow the market to
thrive I don't have I can't point to you
a specific example of what will come to
New Hampshire or what will be created in
New Hampshire because of this bill this
is just us allowing so anything to to
come to
fruition okay representative M um thank
you very much um this seems to me a
little bit like putting the cart before
the horse um I was in the Securities
business for I don't know 40 years and I
don't see how you can you can come up
with a product before you get nasd or
sec approval on this and you're not
talking about that um to me I see a uh a
potential uh Ponzi scheme here I I think
this this is an industry that that
should be very very regulated and this
appears to be going in the different
direction and I think that uh you know
consumers are not going to be protected
thank you
comments moving right
along yes uh so uh I believe you've
answered my qu you've responded to to my
question um I think others have asked
the question can you give an example of
uh of who what and and why not only how
it's working but who what and why do you
believe that there are are others behind
you who will be able to answer that
question because if in fact we have this
legislation enacted into law in other
states then
presumably the legislation is being
utilized and so we would have who's
what's and wise so you believe somebody
else be able to help with that thank you
thank you representative
thanks okay representative Gibbs before
I move over to other thank you um when I
read the bill uh and by the way first of
all let me say I find this a very
interesting idea but it's not one that
I'm previously familiar with um when I
read the bill I couldn't find anything
that specified how long the test would
be whether there was any limit on the
length or any minimum length um can you
give us some information on that that
that would be up to the provider of the
financial service that's in the sandbox
for the length of of it and obviously
with with Communications with the
banking Department as laid out in the
bill uh further question I'm looking at
page seven
here page seven is the banking
commissioner has totally control over
this this sand box so there is a teacher
who overlooks the sandbox
correct sort of but have to here here's
the thing that that got me you could say
is you're looking for a time frame right
the time frame is
that the commission the banking
Department excuse me is going to
assess all the fin all the people who
are being assessed now to fund the bank
and so to me they might just say we
don't want this assessment we don't want
we don't want to pay into this thing and
that will put a kyos to it right out of
the get right out of the block it'll
never happen so the banking Department
would have to approve the length of time
uh further question further question
thank you uh the bill says uh what would
happen if the test failed the what the
participant is supposed to do if the
test failed but it as far as I could
tell it doesn't say what should happen
if the test succeeds that is what the
participant is supposed to do after the
end of a successful test I I would say
if uh the test is successful we should
then legalize whatever framework was in
that test that's on us to I see that you
think that that should be it would come
to us and we would then put it in our
statutes so we would then revise the
statute correct thank you okay did you
do did this is your okay represent Aon
yes
I no we've already heard from her right
oh really yeah well I I believe that but
I'm supposed to I'm supposed to have
everybody go give their one question
before they can ask a second question
we've done this 63 times already this
year all right good good morning
representative so you can't tell us
products that would be in this permitted
under this bill and so and understand my
question is based on someone who has
absolutely lived through two Banking
crisises and been in business and had to
deal with this
crap uh
the so you can't tell us what it might
be can you tell us what it is that we
can't based on this has to go to the
banking commissioner and it would have
to come before this committee to change
the RSA what opportunity is it that
doesn't already exist because my concern
is would you believe that Wells Fargo
Bank of America US Bank and City Bank
sued the banking Commission in the state
of Vermont in in 200
six because they were too restrictive on
the mortgage lending practices in that
state and by
2009 when Vermont had virtually no
banking failures and the rest of the C
country where these Pro these Pro these
products were allowed New Hampshire
mercifully just had a stronger economy
uh they withdrew their
lawsuit so I want to understand what
opportunity are we if we if we change
nothing in our law if just if we stay
right where we are what opportunity is
it that we're missing that if I am a
banker and I decide I want to do
whatever thing we don't know what it is
what is it that opportunity that the
state of New Hampshire is missing out
it's doing US economic harm sure I I
just think in the light in the context
of emerging Technologies and emerging
products especially in the financial
services
industry there's not like if there was
an answer for what product we're missing
out on today it would already be gaining
stream around the country we already
know it I think it's allowing that next
big thing to start developing in New
Hampshire um and it and it may fail it
may succeed and and setting up the
sandbox for that Innovation to take
place so there's not there's not a list
of products that I can point to as that
could come to New Hampshire with this
legislation it's just allowing for the
planting of seeds within that sandbox to
see what it'll
grow
further question may inquire
so all
right what's wrong what is the
restriction on our procedures now what
is it that the banking commissioner
can't allow or why why are we you know
what's the what is overly burdensome now
if I have some new product I won't offer
credit cards at 2% or whatever crazy
thing they want to do well I would say
right now without this leg ation the
statutes don't allow wouldn't allow an
Innovative product to come through so
this is for across the board products
that statutes don't currently allow for
them to be able to work with the baining
commissioner to provide a a limited
offering of it to see how it can work in
New
Hampshire we have a Chicken and the Egg
problem here right okay thank you very
much thank you okay we'll have the bank
commissioner who with her Council
and they are
bill what a pleasure it is to have you
good morning Madam commissioner thank
you for the opportunity to speak with
you today my name for the record my name
is Amelia Galder and I'm the bank
commissioner for the State of New
Hampshire with me is general counsel
Seth saki for the banking department so
the bank as stated the banking
department is neutral about the con cept
of a Sandbox um however I do have
significant concerns about how this
particular bill is drafted um I'm going
to talk about some of the kind of more
procedural aspects that I'm concerned
about and I'm going to turn it over to
Seth to talk about the more scary things
so because I have a lawyer and he can do
that um okay so from a procedural
perspective um I don't think this bill
is set up appropriately with regard to
funding so the banking department is a
self-funded agency we're completely
funded by the entities that we currently
license through fines fees penalties and
at the end of the day an assessment on
banks credit unions and Trust companies
this bill did not include a fiscal note
for us um and to make this happen I
think the banking Department probably
needs at least four positions an
attorney a paralal an administrator and
an investigator to to figure this out
because we have no rules about this
right it's setting up a whole new
program we don't have the resources
currently staff to do that um so that's
kind of the funding issue that I see
right out of the gate um the other
component of it is that the it's kind of
set up once it's going to be
theoretically funded by the applicants
to the program H however
um right now the banking department has
a pretty reason I think pretty
reasonable fee structure that's set by
the legislature um if you think you need
a license from us it's around $500
depending on license type and then we
have an examination regimen that people
um pay for or entities pay for with a
per DM fee we scope those exams to the
to the size and complexity of the entity
um so we try to keep them reasonable um
we have a good relationship with our
lenses certainly if somebody has an
Innovative product I always want to hear
about it so I was actually intrigued to
find out what Innovative product they
feel is being being prevented because I
always want to know about that I sat on
the cryptocurrency commission set forth
by the governor um I try to work with
anyone who's interested in any new
product um so I'm kind of intrigued to
know what's out there that's somehow I'm
blocking from happening because I want
to know about it um and I think it our
current structure allows that and New
Hampshire is a unique State and that if
something is prevented by our laws
people can come in here and tell you
about it and we can work with them to
come in and tell you about it and work
with a solution so I'm not sure that I
just I'm interested to know what who who
wants to do this because I want to work
with them um so that's kind of a a
principle that that I'm concerned about
um another issue is confidentiality so
theoretically if we drafted rules and
people came to us with an application
for an Innovative product presumably
that application and the design of that
product would be subject to some kind of
comment period I would imagine um it
would be a public matter um I think in
other states that's been how this has
been set up and the issue with that is
if you have an in truly Innovative
Financial product you don't want to tell
everyone about it right out of the gate
because then you know you'll have even
as it is that's you know not how things
work now and we still have like right to
know requests that come in for anytime
we get applications filed
um it would be all in the public domain
and I believe in other states I think
Arizona I think there was one in maybe
West Virginia or Kentucky I'm sorry I
don't have the exact data in fresh in my
brain but if you go and look at what
other states have done with sandboxes
that's why they failed because
ultimately nobody wants to apply because
then their Innovative Financial product
becomes public um which eventually it
does anyway when you go to the market
but like that initial startup of that
product can you I imagine you don't want
that to be public um so those are kind
of the procedural aspects and I'm going
to turn it over to S to talk about the
rest okay good morning chairman hunt
members of the committee uh my name is
Seth Zaraki I'm the general counsel at
the New Hampshire banking department so
I'm going to discuss really three
additional areas of potential concern
relating to HB
157 um first as you know uh the sandbox
that would be created by this bill would
be administered by the banking
department and while uh you know we
appreciate the confidence that the bill
drafters have placed in us to run the
sandboxes for all Financial Services I
think it's important to recognize that
we at the banking Department are experts
in banking and certain um Consumer
Credit Industries we aren't for example
experts in the Securities laws or the
Securities industry so while the bill
envisions that the banking department
will consult with applicable state
agencies um in administering the sandbox
and in um reviewing applications the
ongoing supervision of the sandbox
participants appears to be left to the
banking Department alone uh and with
current Staffing and resources I think
it's difficult to say that the banking
Department would be equipped to oversee
the sandbox with regard to financial
services that are outside our normal
regulatory
purview uh the second area I wanted to
address are some consumer protection
issues um and there's three in
particular first if a consumer of a samp
box participant has a complaint where
would that consumer go to file a
complaint and what process what would
the process be by which that complaint
is resolved presumably I would expect
the consumer would come to us at the
banking department at least in the first
instance and then we may need to consult
with the applicable state agency but
that process isn't uh provided for in
the bill that's drafted and in our
experience at the banking Department
having a clearly defined uh statutory
process for resolving consumer
complaints is very useful tool for both
mediating and resolving uh uh concerns
between consumers and business the
second area is that the bill is drafted
does not appear to require clear and
conspicuous uh disclosures to Consumers
of sandbox participants so for example
should a Sandbox participant be required
to to disclose to the consumer that it
does not hold a license from the New
Hampshire banking Department should a
Sandbox participant be required to
disclose to its consumer r that it is
operating under a temporary test that
could end uh in theory at any time there
may be other disclosures um that should
be made to ensure consumers understand
exactly what they're dealing with um and
then the the third area I wanted to
discuss is what happens in the event of
a security breach um of the consu of the
computer systems of the sandbox
participant I think this could be a
concern um for companies that are that
are using new um or emerging
Technologies as this bill is designed to
do and um so what are the sandbox's uh
participants obligations in the event of
a security breach the bill as drafted
does not expressly address this so those
are the three consumer protection issues
that we believe are absent from this
bill and need further um exploration and
these are fundamental consumer issues
that we believe should be addressed
directly in the statute um finally I
wanted to touch on the effective date of
this bill um as drafted the ACT would
take effect on July 1 of this year um
the banking department does not believe
that that date is feasible given that
the time given the time and the
resources that we've discussed that
would be needed to um get the sandbox up
and running um so that concludes my
prepared remarks I had one more thought
as Seth was talking um another thing we
talk about when we come before this
committee a lot is the exemption to the
consumer protection act so one thing
that's not really clear in this bill is
is it an entity that's already licensed
by one of our agencies and is trying to
do a product or is it an entity that's
wholly
unlicensed and wants to come before us
without a license like you know and then
how does that interplay with the
consumer protection act of exemption um
that's really not clear to me from this
um and is concerning because there I in
my opinion there's nothing worse than
not knowing what jurisdiction something
falls under it can create complete
regulatory confusion um so that is also
I think a concern about this bill that I
want to flex flag um so thank you uh for
hearing us and if you have any questions
happy to answer them so you said other
states have passed this uh I don't know
about this version exactly but a Sandbox
okay they had the concept yes right so
has anything ever come out of I don't
believe so I'd have to go and look but
my understanding is very few people I
don't know if in any of these examples I
looked at that anyone actually applied
for anything and that it and most of
them in like the two I looked at they
Sunset it after a while um so just by
operation of law the sandbox possibility
went away perfect okay represent
Gibs thank
you back to a very Elementary Point uh
do either of you know why this bill does
not have a fiscal note no there the
fiscal note is
determined um by uh the speaker uh when
they look at the bill they uh this you
know look at and see is there's a fiscal
need for a fiscal note and then send it
to the department to generate the fiscal
note um given that the department is
self funded maybe they just thought that
the license insured entities would
absorb the
cost I don't know of course all those
banks that are not federally chared
would just love to pay for
this so thank you representative M uh
thank you Mr chairman would would you
believe that this reminds me a little
bit of that uh Fiasco with the gentleman
selling notes which were a security out
of the Meredith Savings Bank and that
was something that uh the bank
commissioner at that time waved all
responsibility for um which I think he
should have I think the guy that was
doing that was operating his own little
sandbox and uh and and really again that
should have been registered security any
comment on that I mean nope okay well we
have a separate Securities Division I I
understand that that's why this I think
they made the point that that the
banking commissioner is is not
necessarily in a position to to cover
all of this that's true representative
Terry uh so I take it from your
testimony that you think this bill uh
needs a lot of work you need a lot of
help uh with this but I did um ask the
sponsor if there were those behind him
who might be able to cite examples for
us so in your research I think I heard
you say you couldn't find anything even
though other states apparently have
enacted this legislation and some of the
legislation I heard you say has
sunsetted so did so in fact did I hear
you correctly that you did not find any
examples of anybody who wanted to play
and was allowed to play in the sandbox
and what happened in the sandbox I don't
have any I could not find any examples
in a preliminary search but I'm happy to
go and do more research for any work
session
thanks okay repres thank you Mr chair
thank you for your testimony I I missed
the your introductory words so I
apologize
um I'm gonna I'll set up my question I
filed a bill and I think uh you and I
spoke about it on the phone ailia uh
about a while ago yes a while ago and I
I I I didn't think uh it would get
through this committee so I withdrew the
bill to save myself some grief so uh but
it was about um uh State chartered banks
that were not FDIC insured so that would
be a financial product and there's
there's a lot of like fintech Innovation
happening uh in that space um there's
there's a bank out of Wyoming called
custodia I think they're registered in
our state uh and they are a State Bank
they're not FDIC insured they don't lend
money so they don't have that risk of
fractional banking that most banks do uh
and they have a lawsuit with the SEC
because the Federal Reserve isn't
granting them uh an account with the
Federal Reserve and so it's it gets to
that dual banking uh concept so if
somebody and and uh a little further uh
the state of coneticut
allows uh uninsured State Banks they
have a certain Charter type that we
don't have that was what my bill was
about but that would I think that would
fall into a category of this legislation
where it's Financial product that we're
not really sure about it's still kind of
shaking out in the GR in the larger
economy but this sandbox idea would and
correct me if I'm wrong but you know is
that a correct understanding um so when
I think about the sandbox we talk about
products in in my my understanding of
what you were discussing with me in the
fall was more of a whole Charter type um
it wasn't exactly like a speedy from
Wyoming but I think a speedy from
Wyoming a special I always forget what
Speedy stands for special purpose dep
institution yep one of those um this
committee has considered those before um
and it um the bill got changed into a
different form um I think that goes to
what I was saying in my testimony
perhaps before you got here that one of
the nice things about New Hampshire is
if somebody has an idea about something
like that they can pick up the phone and
call me call you um we can come before
this committee and figure out if that's
um the direction the legislature wants
to go in I'm not sure you need a Sandbox
to do that and further I would actually
be more concerned about I feel like
something like that should be fully
thought out and it should be fully
fleshed out by the legislature um and it
deserves that kind of attention whereas
um I think this is much narrower and
whenever I hear it spoken of it's about
products and when I think of like a
financial product I think of like a
specific type of loan or you know maybe
a very narrowly drawn business model
that's aimed to get at something but
again I don't know exactly because I'm
not sure what this sponsor had in mind
um for a product that would be um
subject to the sandbox but I think what
you described to me perhaps could fit
under a money transmitter if I remember
correctly under our current regime
perhaps could be its own Charter type
but in my mind that's too big a concept
for a Sandbox I would be nervous about
that in a sandbox I would want the
guidance of the legislature to set that
up and I really think that's is hitting
the
nail which is when I said chicken of the
egg because your job is to regulate and
inforce the statutes yes you and the
idea the idea that we're going to give
you permission to you know create a
guinea pig and create a test model and
then come back and say oh this is great
we we should put it in our stat statute
is again it's it's out it's a you know
you're getting the in front of the the
truck in front of the trailer but you
know it's so you and I think it it
doesn't um take into account the nice
things that we have about New Hampshire
how accessible the legislature is how
how um involved how at the banking
Department we take everyone's call about
any product and are happy to talk to
them so you know so but again the way I
read this is that that it's going to be
something that theoretically statut
would not be possible that's the reason
why they're coming to you if it was
statutorily possible they would just go
ahead and do it so what I read this bill
is that it is there's something
fundamental about it that is the the
current state law violates it and he
says you can't do it to come and ask the
enforcer of that statute to say um won't
you you know let me go and experiment
over here is just right for abuse and
and I'm and I'm happy to engage like I
really want to know what these entity
like if people perceive that our laws
are blocking some Innovative Financial
product I want to know what you would
want to know I would want to know so I
could come to you and talk so you can
come and and put in legislation to
change that yeah fair enough okay we all
sent oh representative pelli thank you
thank you for taking my question it's
it's interesting concept but it
definitely puts a lot of responsibility
on your department to look at the test
the test terminate the test my question
is about liability I mean the product it
doesn't necessarily have to be a retail
type product it could be an Innovative
in tech product but as far as liability
goes if it doesn't whatever it is and it
doesn't work and the LI liability is
significant and there is harm who would
be on the hook
to make restitution and as we see from
bank failures it's the tax taxpayer so
how I'm I'm not sure that's outlined in
the bill no and do you have any insight
into that no I don't um and that was
what I was um uh speaking directly to
about the exemption from the consumer
protection act because if somebody is
subject to the consumer protection act
they're um the Attorney General's office
has jurisdiction over them and consumers
can sue that company directly for treble
damages whereas if somebody if some an
is under our jurisdiction we have
restitution Authority in our statutes to
obtain restitution for that consumer um
if appropriate and bring in enforcement
action and I think that's that's
something that's missing from the
statute that clarity about
that thank you very much oh do
representative Herbert has a
question um my question is basically I
was very surprised to hear
your uh response in in the sense that
um I don't believe the banking
department is that entity that this
gentleman was addressing I was surprised
that I was surprised that he put you on
the on the spot and the fact of the
matter is um the financial sector is uh
incredibly complicated it's very uh
inventive already and um I don't I
really don't want to hear my banking
commissioner say oh yeah sure let's talk
to me because I don't I don't consider
that to be your job and and so um
there's a lot of I mean as somebody who
sold options in derivatives and that
sort of thing I know she made it very
clear that that is part of the
awkwardness of this bill that you're
asking her to be participant of
activities that doesn't fall under her
Ro what I was waiting to hear was it's I
I am the banking commissioner and I
don't think it's appropriate for me to
give any uh advice appointed border Mr
chairman do we have a question or this
sounds argumented my question is why did
why did you uh come in
neutral I mean from my perspective it's
an it was a ridiculous uh well okay so
that all right that's what would you
believe that's would you believe I would
like to know why you why you consider
yourself neutral in this particular
piece of legislation recommended
legislation so from a perspective of is
a Sandbox a good idea that's how I'm
neutral you all get to decide it I'm the
person who provides you with facts about
what I if you tell me you want a Sandbox
it's my job to explain to you how I
think that sandbox should be set up and
operated in a way to protect consumers
so that's what I mean when I say neutral
like from a policy perspective I don't I
don't set the policy the legislature
sets the policy
and I can give you advice about it
representative Ammon she's not the same
I just have another question thank you
um just while you're here uh we've had
discussions about a stable coin uh you
know regulatory framework um something
like that would fall into the sandbox
could potentially fall into the sandbox
I'm just throwing that out there while
you're here you know if you have any
ideas on it I'd have to see what that
means so I don't I'd have to think about
it all we can talk sorry we can talk
about after and that might be State
treasur anyways yeah that
that
okay but in my mind just so you know
what I've been discussing with him is is
that I have a problem with yet the bull
it just needs to be a private entity it
needs to be yeah I wasn't business that
could be regulated by the banking
department so I wasn't talking about a
bullion depository oh you were talking
about something different oh okay so
okay okay I was wrong I was wrong I
misunderstood
thank you very much I have one card
left Sarah Scott
from Americans for
Prosperity New Hampshire and welcome to
the Commerce Committee and you're really
minutes okay turnic on yeah you press
the button thank you uh thank you Mr
chair and members of the committee for
the opportunity to testify here today uh
my name is is Sarah Scott and I'm the
deputy state director for Americans for
Prosperity here in New Hampshire uh this
is a different committee for me usually
I am in a different one so it's nice to
be here and meet all of you um I'm here
to testify in support of HB 1507 so I
know we've talked a lot about what
exactly uh a regulatory sandbox is um so
I kind of wanted to dive into a little
bit more of your questions rather than
the testimony I was prepared to give
today um that would be great so
essentially the regulat sandbox is a
testing ground for new Innovative
products or Services um it's essentially
a way to keep the consumer safe while
allowing the business the opportunity to
come up with new innovative ideas and to
have that discussion with the regulators
and kind of figure out what are the gaps
that we're seeing why like what is
currently blocking them from having
these kinds of products so I don't think
the goal is to um cater this to a
specific business that's saying you know
something is currently blocking us
because I do agree that if the case is
that there's something a current law or
regulation we do have the process to go
through the legislature and address that
I think this is more focused on products
that we don't know how they fit yet into
our regulatory structure uh Financial
technology in part particular is just
moving at such a rapid Pace that our
regulations just can't necessarily keep
up with it um so something that even if
we updated which we do rules and
regulations every single year somebody
is always coming up with a new idea that
we just hadn't even thought of so this
provides that framework to work with the
regulators and the banking commission to
kind of figure out what that looks like
so that we could come to the legislature
and say these are the things that we
need to change for all
businesses um so right now I think 14
states have passed a framework for this
some kind of sandbox some are looking
specifically at the financial technology
industry some of them are broadening
that out to Encompass other Industries
as well uh but right now there are 14
states that have passed that and I
believe that there are only 14 states
that have not considered the legislation
or aren't in the process of that right
now so it's definitely something that a
lot of other states especially in the
Northeast I think uh Massachusetts is
looking at this legislation this year um
I did hear something about Rhode Island
as well I can't speak to the specifics
on that that was just something that um
somebody had shared with me yesterday um
so it's something that I think is going
to be a continu conversation over the
next several years as more and more
States look at how they are going to be
kind of that Beacon for Innovation and
entrepreneurs and so I think really this
is a lot about showing businesses that
we are the spot to welcome them in that
we are happy to work with them to figure
out how their business might fit in with
our current structure or what needs to
be changed I know we do have a very
accessible legislature and the banking
Department um I think that giving kind
of like a framework for this and saying
we have a sandbox is a great way to be
that Beacon that we like to be um in
general for New Hampshire you know we
like to pride ourselves on being the
place that people want to move to
whether it's um you know the best place
to raise a family the best place to
start a business we also want to be that
Beacon uh in the Northeast for
entrepreneurs and innovators to make
sure that they are looking to us as a
place to start up their
Industries um I did want to
mention see the uh this is has been a
bipartisan movement uh across all of
these states so it's not something that
it's only Republicans or only Democrats
working on I always really enjoy seeing
that bipartisan effort people working
together on this I think it's a very
complicated issue and definitely
something that's going to need some
thought and work um but I think it would
be something that you know a lot of
other states are considering and it' be
important for us here in New Hampshire
to uh do the same happy to take
questions representative Terry has a
question so I'm sitting here and I'm
reminded of the move
uh The Matrix and the question is he the
one and I'm wondering is she the one are
you able to give me examples you've
cited 14 states where this legislation
has been ected are you familiar enough
with this issue so that you can give us
an example or two of what and why so
thank you yes so I'm going to look it up
on my phone here I have the list open
there are currently 37 businesses that
have gone through or are currently in a
sandbox across the 14 States so it's not
something that we're seeing you know
like 40 or 50 businesses applying for in
every state I think it's something that
for the most part we're expecting that
the regulations aren't overly bomson but
there are some Innovative Technologies
that we haven't kind of come for yet
follow so since there are 37 can you can
you site one descri
yes why it's in yep that's what I was
just getting to next have the list open
here um so for example I'll just read
off one of them uh called grain
technology Inc so it's an application
that offers consumers personalized
saving plans and credit opportunities
through their existing bank account um
there's another one Omni Mobile Inc uh
which is a financial service platform
implementing an array of uh Technologies
to improve today's payment systems
through the utilization of direct AC uh
payments through om Central CZ wallet
infrastructure um a lot of these I'll
say I don't have the technological
wherewithal to understand the technology
but there's a list that I'd be happy to
send around of what those uh different
businesses are that would be great it's
it's listed on like the what the states
yes it's listed on each of the states
websites so I'll just send you the link
to each of the states so you have to
click through and see that that would be
spear
I want to say this question correctly
but uh we just heard from the banking uh
commissioner that they have some very
serious concerns about consumer
protection and the bill has nothing in
there for that in
reality and you you said that this was
all for the consumer and you know
stressed all that even in light of the
fact that this bill has no consumer
protection uh are you folks considering
rewriting this or just leaving it this
way I am not the author of this bill um
so I couldn't speak to the original
intent but I believe this is the
language that was passed in other states
so I think it would be fine to I don't
think the intent of this is to uh you
know take people out of that consumer
protection act I think that adding
Clarity to that could be helpful um I
don't have an opposition to that so
represent spirit I will entertain the
question but can we be a little more
specific to the bill or something rather
than rather than the 6 excuse me I'll
just go by the link the links that she
said I will go to the state all the
states and go look it all up perfect
great see none thank you very much thank
you very much is there anyone else who
would like to testify Bankers don't want
to
testify um representative grassy do you
mind looking at the blue sheet for me
and and you know what let's do it let's
change our system here why don't you
just read nothing's here blank okay I
was going to have you just read it out
rather than having to pass it around uh
with that we will close the public
hearing and uh see you all after lunch
for our exec session if anybody has
written testimony could you just
please
you no I'm all right I think okay uh
1183 and I look like I'm the one making
the motion okay um so we're uh my motion
is to interim study seconded by
representative
pusc uh prohibiting sale of agricultural
land and land essential the critical
Industries to China um this is an
ongoing issue across R the country and
uh so we want to make sure we have a
vehicle available for us here in the
Commerce Committee if this was ever
going to be a problem or something has
coming up in New Hampshire we want to be
able to act quickly so the best way to
do that is to hold this bill uh as a
interim
study any discussion on the motion of
study seeing none the clerk will call
the
role there it
is
interim study motion motion
yes represented
gra
sorry you turn on your speaker oh sorry
thank you how did he get there well
Republican well well because he replaced
no he
didn't you're having fun all right uh
representative pusk
yes uh representative Terry yes
representative post yes
representative anber Ankerberg Ankerberg
Ankerberg yes how do you vote
Yes okay uh representative
pelli oh where she was here this morning
she's um testifying oh okay so nothing
representative
taxton representative Walsh
yes representative Burrows yes
representative Herbert yes
representative clerk votes yes uh
representative mcclear
yes um and who's re Lisa
yes okay
[Music]
so okay representative Gibbs yes you are
next uh representative spear yes
representative
Sullivan and chair hunt yes
yes okay motion so yeah and
representative MCU votes yes yes uh how
did
I he's the one that replaces osbor oh
there you go see your name wasn't even
on here I should know that grass you
replace Sean
right no one two three 19 because we're
missing 19 to zero portelli okay motion
passes vote 19 to zip all those in favor
of placing on the consent Calendar
please say I I I those opposed to move
damous Sly IA I need to work on this I
am okay uh House Bill 1198 relative to
liquor
stores uh representative pusk second by
representative Ammon Mo ought to pass
representative pusk is recognized to
speak to his
motion thank you Mr chair
um the committee agrees that
uh Highway stores that have a lot of
traffic should be open for business uh
and because it makes more money for the
state so plain and simple okay the
committee passed this legislation last
year the Senate killed it but we're
going to give it one more try and hope
that the Senate might see their way with
this bill okay any more discussion on
the ought to pass
rooll representative Ammon yes
okay so it would be you that's no who's
who's
he replaced by m right there you are
yes sorry uh representative
pusk yes representative Terry yes
representative post
yes um Ankerberg yes okay
thanks
uh representative p uh pelli no she's
representative representative Walsh yes
representative barrows yes
representative Herbert yes clerk yes
maer
yes representative Carrie
yes representative Calabro
yes representative grassy
he left okay uh representative Gibbs
yes representative spear
yes representative
Sullivan and share
hun
yes okay so that's 18 18 is zip all L
all those in favor placing on the
consent calend please say I I I those
opposed so move
unanimously
Mia okay well he's going to come back
right he's just testifying testifying
okay what was the you you want you want
to write the
leave
okay
all right so the motion is uh interim
study seconded by representative
Burrows are we on we're on 127 127
single use single use
Y and would you like to speak to your
motion represent I move inter room study
we feel that there are some good ideas
behind this however the actual um lack
of parody across Commerce is an issue
there's a number of other issues with
this bill I'll try and um illuminate
that but the cost to the consumers in
the industry right now are pretty
prohibitive they're running in single
digigit margins and um this is just not
the time to introduce this particular
type of legislation but if the economy
should get better it's certainly
something to consider thank
you okay any other discussion on the
motion of House Bill 1207 seeing none
yes oh that's m m sorry yes there's too
many names on
here uh representative pusk yes uh Terry
yes post
yes Ankerberg
yes thanks
uh pachell
Faxton um representative Walsh
yes uh barrows yes Herbert here
yes clerk yes Maier
yes um Vincent representative Carrie
yes uh
representative Calabro
yes he's not here either representative
spere
yes oops oh sorry representative Gibbs
yes uh
Sullivan and chairman hunt yes so 18 to
zero okay motion carries all those in
favor placing on the consent Calendar
please say I I those oppos so
1232 uh representative Spears seconded
by representative pusk moves uh interum
study representative Spears recognizes
speak to her motion the uh Federal
Reserve has not made any determination
as yet as to what a central bank digital
currency looks like and they have also
indicated that it will take a law being
passed by the by Congress so until we
find a little more clarity on what this
is
uh we're going to S we're going to study
it for a while and make sure we know
what's going on before we decide to ban
something that we don't know what it
is great any more discussion on the
motion seeing none the clerk will call
the
role representative Ammon yes mugh
yes pusk yes Terry yes post
yes Ankerberg yes
than
you right uh represent
pachelli pachelli don't worry I can't
pronounce her name either representative
pachelli she's not here not oh I'm
looking at
collabo um
Saxon so how many martinis did you have
a
Walsh Burrows yes Herbert she she she'll
Ankerberg clerk yes uh M yes
inberg representative two
votes representative Calabro yes and
grass is not here representative Gibbs
yes Carrie still needs to be counted
representative spere
yes Sullivan yes jamman hunt yes oh 18
it excuse
me oh oh oh oh oh sorry it's okay I did
just just think Mariah in your head okay
dancing across the boat even I even I
checked off did I even call did I call
Vin Mariah because I checked off in I
should have okay we're good she just
said think I'm I want I want what she
had okay well there's a lot of I know I
okay 18 all those in favor of placing
House Bill uh 1232 on the on the consent
Calendar please say I those opposed so
moved
unanimously it's not I I had to do clerk
one one year that was that was enough
1406 uh and let's see I have
representative
spear in expedient to legislate seconded
by represent
bullo represent spe you recognize to
speak to your motion okay yeah yes thank
you uh this bill wanted to uh ban the
ability of a producer of a manufacturer
for selling uh products that were geared
towards women specifically at a higher
rate than those de uh geared towards men
however uh it would be almost according
to the uh justice department it would be
almost impossible to tell the difference
between such a deliberate act and
whether or not it had anything to do
with a production run for instance if
something is pink for instance it may
have a very short production run and
therefore cost more money just because
of that so since is almost unenforcable
and we had no one here uh claiming that
they had Dam been damaged by this we
decided to itl it
Bill see none the Kirk will call the
role
right representative Ammon yes MCU yes
yes um belli is not here
taxton Walsh yes Barrow yes
Herbert clerk yes melier
yes representative Kerry
yes representative
Calabro
yes and Grassi is not
in okay what thank you John we're good
uh representative Gibbs yes
spear yes
Sullivan and chairman
hunt
yes 18 Z 18 Z okay the vote is 18 to zip
uh all those in favor placing on the
consent Calendar please say I those
opposed so moveed
damous all right next up is uh House
Bill
1621 and representative buo second by
representative hunt moves uh interim
study and representative buo recognize
to speak to her motion Li stor we had
this discussion yesterday that is
correct in a subcommittee and uh the the
sponsor wanted to uh wanted the Liquor
Commission
to
um post information about um
preventative measures and alcoholism and
um and they
decid stop no
so the they the uh sponsor also wanted
um pamphlets to be dist distributed in
the liquor stores The Liquor Commission
provided us information regarding a
video that was going to be produced by
The Liquor Commission um in partnership
with vendors um using grant funding uh
to produce information about the uh 988
uh number for people that are in uh
distress so um we came up with uh
interim study because that was the thing
to
do okay any other discussion on the
motion of interim
study seeing none the clerk will call
the
role
and this is for interim study correct
representative Ammon
yes representative MCU yes pusk yes
Terry yes post yes Ankerberg
yes pachelli
yes
Faxton Walsh yes buros yes Herbert yes
yes representative carry
yes Cabell
yes no he's not here Gibbs yes spear yes
Sullivan and rep uh chairman hunt yes 18
to
zero 19 19
oh okay motion passes 19 is zero all
those in favor of placing on the consent
Calendar please say I I those opposed so
mooved
unanimously okay so we're going to skip
over the Canabis
1633 uh and just to remind everybody we
will be doing a subcommittee on that um
Tuesday
morning and you will see because
actually Carrie already sent it out so
what uh my strategy is that um we have
18 liquor bills in which obviously the
candid was considered one of them um we
will we will spend the rest of the day
discussing in subcommittee the liquor
subcommittee um all those different
bills and what we want to do with them
so um that that will be Tuesday and then
we'll be executing on Wednesday uh
afternoon and we'll be doing health
insurance in the morning of Wednesday
morning I think there's only four four
bills for health insurance okay moving
1636 representative Thaxton seconded by
representative pusc moves um inim study
and representative taxon is recognized
to speak to his
motion all this bill this is regarding
uh motion to interim study HB 1636 FN
this bill establishes a new hire
container deposit refund recycl and
reuse system it establishes a producer
responsibility
organization to implement a beverage
container recycling Redemption refund
program to issue Redemption refunds to
consumers or beverage containers it
contains labeling requirements
establishing performance targets for the
pro contains reporting requirements
requires the pro to establish an
operations advisory committee and an
equity and access advisory committee and
contains Provisions concerning
reimbursements and Enforcement
Administration and other Provisions this
proposal being a complex combination of
public and private stakeholders requires
a greater study before this committee
can make an informed recommendation to
the house we recommend this bill be
moved to interim study before a final
taken perfect any more discussion on the
motion of interim
study uh seeing none the clerk will call
the
okay this is
1636 interim
study representative Ammon yes
representative mugh yes representative
pusk yes Terry yes post
yes uh
pelli represent p
yes uh representative taxton yes Walsh
yes Eros yes Herbert yes clerk yes maer
yes Vincent uh representative carry
yes collabo
yes he's not here Gibbs
yes spear yes
Sullivan yes and chairman hunt
yes 19 vote is 19 to zip all those in
favor of placing on the consent Calendar
unanimously okay next up um House Bill
1645 establishing a condu dispute
resolution board representative thaon
seconded by
representative pusc M's uh interim study
and representative taxon's recognized to
speak to his motion this is a motion to
interim study HB 1645 this bill
establishes a condominium dispute
dispute resolution board and the
position of board administrator in the
department of administrative services to
resolved matters involving condominium
associations and unit owners this bill
also makes an appropriation to the
Department of administrative services
for the purpose of funding the position
this proposal being a complex
combination of public public and private
stakeholders requires greater study
before this committee can make an
informed recommendation to the house the
motion is for interim
study any discussion on the motion of
interim study seeing none the clerk will
call the
role representative Ammon
yes McHugh yes pusk yes Terry yes post
yes
Cole Anor an yes
sorry I have it right here too uh
pachelli
yes
taxton Walsh yes Burrows yes Herbert yes
clerk yes melier
yes Carrie
yes cabro
yes he's not here Gibbs
yes spear yes Sullivan yes chamman hun
yes 19 motion is uh 19 to zip all those
in favor of placing on the consent
Calendar please say I I those opposed so
moved
unanimously so not to say that Commerce
doesn't pass something here we go 1649
relative to proh prohibiting certain
products with intentionally
unintentionally added intentionally
added p uh representative spear seconded
by representative have an amendment
Burrows ought to pass on the amendment
and the amendment number
is32 wait there Amendment for p did you
get that this is this the one that this
is Pas I know but is this who put in the
amendment uh
I'm sorry I I didn't have it in front of
me so I guess I should have adoption of
amendment
is right you think this committee would
equipped yeah we want to make sure we
number
should be can you refresh our memory on
what the
amendment
says okay can you refresh our memory on
what the amendment says so
representative spear is recognized to
motion
uh the the original Bill uh had in it
some uh features that uh well let me
start from the beginning th this bill
and the amendment was made uh as a
bipartisan effort to address a very
severe problem that's happening in New
Hampshire with respect to the pest uh
contamination that we face in our
wellwater and our land waste in uh
products that we use most
commonly uh with the a very high past
load the original Amendment had in it
some uh some uh labeling
requirements and uh another couple of
features and in order to address the
opposition those features were taken out
so it's essentially the same bill as
what it was before but we addressed all
of the
opposition discussions that went on in
the committee meeting and the final bill
is represented by this uh
Amendment we're going to with this
amendment and if we pass it it joins 14
States in trying to address this problem
some states have taking much more severe
approaches than we're
taking but we feel in this environment
that this is the best bang we can get
for our buck if you will in addressing a
us
great okay any other discussion on the
motion represent Ammon thank you I just
want to State my position on on this
bill I'm going to be voting yes on the
amendment and no on the final passage of
the bill I'm worried that we're Banning
products that are useful in the
marketplace without hard concrete
evidence to support it and I'm not
discussing the bill I'm stating my my
uh representative
Axton uh my position is exactly the same
as that of Representative
Ammon
okay so um I I got a phone call uh or
actually an email from Bia and telling
me they want to be in opposition to this
bill and I go well where have you been
and that we have multiple times I have
asked for if there's any opposition to
this bill please speak up forever more
hold your peace um having said that um I
do believe that we have narrowed it to
with this amendment we have narrowed it
down to uh only a handful of items uh
but that upon my insistence we have uh a
section for um uh exemptions and I will
I go on public record right now on
YouTube that any company in New
Hampshire that has a product that they
cannot
replace uh please and then somehow got
included in this list please let me know
and we will absolutely look at it and
and and consider to adding it to the
exemption list but at this point the
problem is that um I think even
manufacturers probably have no idea
whether there's PS in their products or
not because they're getting from third
party suppliers who may or may not tell
them that what's in in that product
representative spear there was a
requirement by the EPA that everyone
every manufacturer and distributor of
pasas put their P formulations into a
database that the EPA is responsible for
so they better pretty quick on figure
out whether or not they have pasas so I
don't think that they can really rely on
just pretending they don't know know and
we heard Witnesses especially from the
dees that said if there is a question
the dees will test it right and they
have that capability and that and that's
really in terms of the other piece that
we've done in this bill is to model it
what we did with Mercury in terms of
creating this uh clearing house uh using
a a Consortium of other states and the
Clearing House and so that we're not
Reinventing the me the wheel here and
dealing with pas we are basically
picking up where where we did with
Mercury and I'm pretty sure I don't see
any Mercury around um the end of the day
I the most important thing the message I
want everyone to understand is was
driving this legislation is the waste
system and that is that if um if if I
was Waste Management who did come in and
support of the bill um I would be
deathly afraid that that this product
some of the stuff would show up in my
landfill without me knowing it and then
it somehow seeped out and they would be
liable and so it's already there there's
no doubt past is everywhere right it's
in all of us already we just don't know
how much we have so so the idea is that
this somehow we've got to to stop the
train uh and terms of having this past
showing up into our waste
system so with that the clerk will call
the role on ought to pass on the
amendment
great thank you for that are you now A
D
yep you had your mic on this is very
serious all right so this is uh
649 um as amended
um on the on the
amendment pass on the amend I got it I'm
going over the motion is ought to pass
on the
amendment all
right representative Ammon yes on the
amendment mugh
yes pusk yes Terry yes post yes
Ankerberg
yes pelli
yes Daxton
yes Walsh
yes burrow yes Herbert yes clerk yes
Maier
yes here Gibbs yes spear yes
Sullivan chairman hunt
yes okay now the motion is all to pass
the vote as Z 19 to Z 19 to zero motion
now is ought to pass as amended uh is
there any discussion on the
motion seeing none the clerk will call
the role uh who's moving it same Spear
and excuse me representative spear
second by representative burough okay
and the motion is ought to pass as
right
representative Ammon
no representative MCU
yes representative pusk yes Terry yes
no pelli
no Walsh yes thank you Burrows yes
Herbert clerk yes melier
yes Terry
yes glabro
yes Gibbs yes spear yes Sullivan yes
chairman hug
yes all right so we have 16
okay 163 we will leave this on the
regular calendar excellent thank you
very much okay last but not least House
Bill 1674 establishing to relative to
establishing the New Hampshire legal
tender act and establishing a state
bullion
depository uh representative th thax
sorry second by representative pusc
moves interim study and representative
taxon is recognized to speak to his
motion
this is a motion to interim study HB
1674 this bill establishes the New
Hampshire legal tender act establishes
gold and silver as legal tender
establishes estate depository and
enables digital use of gold and silver
this proposal being a complex
combination of public and private
stakeholders requires greater study
before this committee can make an
informed recommendation to the house we
recommend this bill be moved to interim
representative Ammon uh thank you Mr
chair so I will be uh voting against ANM
study and I just want to explain why uh
first of all it's my bill so I don't
want to vote against myself um but I
want to make it clear I want to I I
would like to write a minority blurb and
just make it clear that there was an
amendment uh that limited the bill down
to just the legal tender portion and uh
and I'll say some things in the blur
about the size of the national debt and
how we're approaching what's called a
multi-polar world where dollar dominance
may not be around much longer um because
other countries are are doing things
that circumvent the dollar so we have to
think about that as a state
because if inflation comes home to roost
then that affects our our citizens so
that that would be my my thinking behind
uh going against the committee and I
realize I may be alone in that but I'm
okay any other discussion on the motion
of interim study for 1674 question yeah
so to uh representative ammon's
concern uh if the bill is approved to go
to interim study is is his concern still
alive and and therefore it it could come
back to us uh with a broader scope than
what it has apparently been narrowed
to um may I ask representative Amon that
question sure uh so um interim study is
uh death With Dignity for the bill so
that's how I'm looking at this and and
and it's okay um the amendment just
narrowed it down to one portion the bill
had three different parts that narrowed
down to one my my preference would have
been to work on that and uh get that
Amendment passed but I realized that's
not feasible so uh that's my assessment
okay I'm sorry I naively believed that
it was actually going to be studied
rather than go to die thank
you um obviously I I will always take
the perception that any bill that's in
our committee when we have whether we
retained it or inim study it is always
up for discussion at any time and
certainly um as I even said it when when
we came to orientate the the uh Orient
well I guess it was a continue education
um I treat study committees as a very
important vehicle uh uh format in which
we can have those discussions uh and we
do have an obligation to to meet on it
and next fall and um and I would say
that that uh representative am and I
have I I we had some ideas about how we
were going to go about it uh but a
little there was a little critical piece
that we couldn't come together so but
that fair good all right uh the motion
is uh interim study for house bills
1674 the clerk will call the role y
no McHugh
no
yes Terry
post no
Ankerberg
noelli
yes
taxton
yes Walsh
yes Barrow yes
yes mle yes representative kry yes cabro
yes
Gibbs yes spear yes Sullivan yes and
chairman hun
yes all right so we have 18 13 to five
13 to five we will leave that on the
regular
calendar is it
13 no okay it's 14 I think it's 14 to 5
yeah I think it's 14 to 5 y 19 yeah got
to be 14
14 okay okay uh chair will rule we're
out of EXA
session
wow I didn't I I shouldn't have gone off
to lunch because I should have been
down the question is whether you would
get up
I'm
were
list